I've been having this crazy recurring
dream lately the dream is about the
future of laptops and computing I know
it's weird but it's of a post PC device
that combines the best of my laptop the
MacBook Air with the best of a tablet
with no compromises but then this weird
thing happened in my dream last week
Microsoft introduced the surface pro 3
and told me the dream had come true with
a larger HD screen a new keyboard and
improved kickstand
and a $7.99 starting price Microsoft is
confident that the surface pro 3 is it
the tablet to replace my tablet but my
beloved 13-inch MacBook Air but while
this surface certainly leaps forward and
bringing the tablet and the laptop
together and bringing the laptop into
the future there are still considerable
compromises you make for getting
everything in one package let's first
talk about the surface as a tablet
Microsoft is calling it a tablet of
course the device is impressively thin
and even with a 12 inch screen it only
weighs 1.76 pounds that's much thinner
than the MacBook Air but not as thin as
Apple's iPad air and not as light either
holding it up to read on can be very
uncomfortable no really my arm feels
like it's gonna fall off right now not
to mention the sides can get really warm
during processor intensive tasks or even
just streaming video that's of course
because inside here are the guts of a
laptop but Microsoft figures you'll be
keeping this on your lap which is why
it's put so much into improving the lap
ability that's a made up Microsoft Word
by the way now you can adjust the
kickstand to your liking to better
position it on your legs
it no longer falls off my lap as much
but because you can't just push back the
screen it takes longer than a laptop to
get just right but the surface doesn't
look or feel like a laptop competitor
till you clicking that keyboard cover
which still oddly is not included with
the surface the type cover cost 130
dollars I really like that the keyboard
can now be propped up instead of laying
completely flat the trackpad has also
been improved and enlarged but it's
still very frustrating to use not only
is it too
small but sometimes scrolling doesn't
work and the cursor can easily jump when
you're typing bottom line you'll want to
use a bluetooth mouse you'll also want
to go shopping for a USB expander or
that $200 docking station since it only
has one USB port and when you start
plugging in those peripherals it starts
looking like it has dreadlocks if you
really want the surface to replace your
laptop the price starts adding up the
mouse the keyboard the docking station
but what Microsoft does include in the
box is a stylus which is useful for
taking notes and pretty fun to play with
but there's no slot for it go in my
dreams
wearing a stylus necklace is very cool
with all that setup the surface becomes
a workhorse everything runs smoothly and
the new aspect ratio of the
high-resolution screen makes it easy to
put windows side-by-side I love that
feature but I still find Windows 8.1
complicated to use and just disjointed
battery life is much better than the
last surface and Microsoft deserves
credit for matching the battery life of
the latest ultra box still it doesn't
live up to the all-day promise the
surface stream video for seven hours
while the MacBook Air lasted nearly nine
and a half hours on the same test but
it's pretty incredible how much power
and features they've crammed into such
an incredibly thin device that said the
pro 3 still suffers from the surface
curse it isn't as good as other tablets
for tablet things and it isn't as good
of a laptop as my MacBook Air so is this
the post PC computer of my dreams no but
it's the closest thing on the market
which means I guess I'll keep having
more crazy dreams